hey 42 here when angela hernandez
decided to go for a drive down highway
one in southern california
she had no idea that grim reaper himself
would be following her angela was
passing through big sir on the way to
visit her sister
when suddenly a small animal leapt out
into the road ahead reacting on instinct
she swerved avoiding the animal by mere
injures
unfortunately she also managed to avoid
the rest of the road while she was at it
as her car careened off course there was
a sickening moment
when the world fell away beneath her and
then
everything went black
when angela awoke some time later she
found herself trapped in her wrecked car
with sea water pouring in around her
ankles the first thing that had hit her
was the pain
which seemed to be radiating from every
part of her body
as it turned out she'd fractured four
ribs broken both her collarbones
ruptured blood vessels in both of her
eyes punctured her lung
and had suffered a brain hemorrhage
angela had driven over the edge of a
cliff
her vehicle smashing into the rocky
beach that weighted 250 feet below
if ever a car accident should have
proven fatal
it was this one and yet somehow
angela was alive trapped in the assorted
collection of metal rubber and plastic
that had recently been her
2011 jeep patriot and equally trapped
inside her newly mangled body
angela summoned the strength to reach
for the multi-tools she kept stashed in
the glove box
and smashed her way out of the
miraculously still intact driver's side
window
free of the wreckage she splashed
through the surf and up onto the beach
where
her strength depleted she promptly
passed out
when she finally awoke several hours
later she hauled herself to her feet
which were now bare and began to do what
i suspect anyone would have done in her
place
scream at the top of her lungs well
lung not that it made any difference
she was 250 feet below the highway
at the bottom of a near vertical cliff
she was alone and considering the
severity of her injuries
she was running out of time if the grim
reaper had been following
her down the highway the night before by
now
he must have been tapping his foot
impatiently and pointing at
his watch suddenly feeling an intense
first
angela searched a wreck of her car for
the gallon of water she always kept in
the trunk
but to her dismay it was nowhere to be
seen
scavenging a severed radiator hose she
began to collect water from mossy
patches along the shoreline
telling herself all the while that
somebody would be along
soon to rescue her but
nobody came for the next seven days
she lived off the small amount of water
she could harvest
trying in vain to find a way off the
beach as she avoided
swarms of crabs and attempted to stay
out of the burning sunshine
at night she ventured as high up the
cliff face as she could
trying to sleep despite the terrible
pain in her body
and the knowledge that she was slowly
falling prey to dehydration
and surely death
this was her state of mind night after
night
as she lay gazing up at the big dipper
sparkling above
in the vast expanse of space a somewhat
ironic navigational landmark
well space mark given she had nowhere to
go
but little did she know this was all
about to change
waking up next morning in the hot
californian sun
angela somewhat delirious from
dehydration found herself
looking upon a mirage there was a woman
wandering along the beach below it was a
dream she'd had more than once
over the previous few nights likely her
aching desire to be found
manifesting itself before her very eyes
only this time it wasn't
the woman was real and angelo was saved
within hours she had been airlifted to
safety by a rescue team
and reunited with her family who had
searched for her relentlessly
the entire time she had been missing and
what's the lesson we can all learn from
this
pack a multi-tool damn it's a shame i
didn't get this video sponsored by
leverman
oh and if an animal happens to run
across your path when you're driving
run the damn thing over cheating death
is no easy task
and it's even harder when you're on your
own with limited provisions
and mother nature as being an utter
[ __ ] doing everything in her
considerable power
to end your life yet some people have
managed to do
exactly that become the stars of some of
the most
astonishing survival stories in human
history in the process
for these people when death himself came
calling they did not simply go gentle
into that good night
they fought that skeletal bastard back
no
as terrifying as it must be to plummet
250 feet off a cliff
finding yourself stranded on a beach as
your brain hemorrhages
there are plenty of other ways to push a
human being to his
limits the just gone 4 was 12 miles off
the coast of nigeria when it capsized
batted by the relentless atlantic ocean
the craft began to sink
some of the 12 man crew were lost
beneath the waves
others scrambled to find their life
jackets and prepared
to swim for it but for one crew member
[ __ ] was about to get real literally
the ship's cook harrison oakeen
was on the toilet we can only imagine
those first few seconds
as the ship capsized and he found
himself
wearing the fruits of his recent labors
but
harrison soon had more pressing things
to worry about
freezing water blasted through the ship
as it was swallowed whole by the ocean
and like the world's filthiest ragdoll
harrison was swept from one cubicle to
the next
within a matter of seconds a ship
crashed into the seafloor
1200 feet below the surface in pitch
darkness and with water rapidly rising
all around him
harrison cried out repeatedly in the
hope that he wasn't alone in the world's
least capable submarine
nobody responded with one hand on the
roof to guide him
he half stumbled half swam from room to
room desperately searching for a stable
pocket of air
in a stroke of luck he found one but the
sense of relief did not last long
even in the darkness harrison could tell
this pocket of air wasn't
large and there was still a small matter
of the hundred feet of freezing ocean
that sat between him
and the sky far above there has perhaps
never been a man more doomed to die than
this
death had arranged to pieces rigged the
board
paid off the jury loaded the dice and
was running through a series of gentle
stretches in preparation for
one final swing of his scythe
as the air was running out and all
harrison had for sustenance
was a single can of coke he'd found half
submerged
nearby his body was beginning to become
saturated with dissolved nitrogen
and the freezing water was gradually
sapping his body of heat
at any moment the ocean might have
swallowed him entirely
instead it was content to leave him in
stark
desolate terror for now for 60 hours
across almost three days
harris and oaken remained alone at the
bottom of the ocean
in utter darkness crying and praying
but the only response was the resonating
echo of his own helplessness
and as the minutes hit by he grew colder
hungrier
more tired and more certain that the
pocket of air he had found
was not to be his salvation but his tomb
and then the impossible happened
a faint shimmering light appeared
beneath the water
followed by a murky shadow suddenly
something clutched at his hand as a
shape broke clear of the water
it was the goggled head of a diver
staring at harrison
in astonishment the diver was part of a
team sent to recover corpses from the
ship
instead he had found harris and oaken a
living
breathing man sat at the bottom of the
sea
enjoying a coca-cola despite all odds
harrison was saved on reaching the
surface some hours later he vowed never
to set foot on a ship again
what lesson can we learn from his ordeal
no matter how desperate you are
if the ship you're on flips upside down
and starts plummeting beneath the waves
it's time to wipe flush and re-evaluate
your priorities
what's worse than being trapped at the
bottom of the ocean mid [ __ ]
well being up [ __ ] creek with a mexican
fisherman
on november the 17th 2012 a fisherman by
the name of jose salvador alvarenga
departed from the southern coast of
chiapas state mexico
he was in a small modest boat
accompanied by a man named as queer
cordoba
the two men had set out to catch a few
tuna sharks and mahi mahi over the
course of the next 30 hours
you know modest fishing goals neither
man had worked with the other before
or even spoken little did they know
they were about to get extremely well
acquainted
within a few hours they were caught in a
violent storm that swept them out into
open ocean
the storm lasted for five full days and
sent their boat careening off course
destroying the ship's radio and motor
in the process a search party spent two
days looking for them but
eventually gave up and assumed the men
had drowned
with no food no supplies no motor
no means of contacting help and stuck
drifting miles out in the unforgiving
pacific ocean
the pair of fishermen had no choice but
to helplessly float
wherever the currents took them
surviving off what food
they could catch and whatever rain water
they could collect
they ate turtles and drank their blood
consumed jellyfish apparently you can do
that
and ate whatever raw fish they could get
their hands on
they even drank their own urine days at
sea
turned to weeks and weeks turned to
months
they were lost in the largest ocean on
the planet
so large in fact that it covers some 32
percent of the total surface of the
earth
it became very clear to both men that
nobody
was coming to rescue them soon cordoba
became sick
vomiting and delirious from one too many
sushi dinners
without any chance of medical attention
he lost all hope
refused to eat and died
now alvarenga was alone contemplating
suicide as he
drifted into the endless ocean cordoba
had made alvarenga promised that he
would not consume his body
and alvarengo agreed keeping the corpse
on the boat and even speaking to it
before realizing that was batshit insane
and throwing his ears while fishing
buddy overboard
now alone alvarenga continued to drift
counting time by keeping track of lunar
cycles
and trying to solicit help from passing
freighters all
of which ignored him but on the 15th
lunar cycle
something changed in the distance was a
tiny desolate island
the first sign of land in as long as
alvarenga could remember
having no idea where it was or even if
the island was inhabited
the skeletal man flung himself into the
ocean abandoned his boat
and swam for the shore at the point of
exhaustion
alvarenga crawled onto dry land and
began to search frantically for any sign
of life
eventually he found it a twelve thousand
pound polar bear inexplicably charging
at him on this remote tropical island
and a mysterious hatch door oh no sorry
that was something else he stumbled upon
a modest hut
belonging to an elderly couple he had
found civilization
alvarenga was on the marshall island in
the middle of the pacific ocean
having completed the longest journey for
a person
lost at sea ever he had been adrift
for 438 days
well over a year and had traveled across
500 miles of open ocean jose salvador
alvarenga had survived an ordeal
so impossible that many people simply
refused to believe his story
until records from mexico confirmed it
so what's the lesson this time turtles
may be cute
but if you're lost at sea it's totally
fine to slaughter them without mercy
and voraciously consume their blood now
regular viewers might already be
familiar with this next story but for
those who aren't
it must be told because it's one of the
greatest examples of cheating death
known to man by the early 1900s ernest
shackleton was already one of the
world's greatest explorers
but it was in 1914 that something truly
horrifying yet remarkable happened to
him
and his crew he had set out on a
legendary journey to cross antarctica on
foot
this in itself is no mean feat
especially considering the technology of
the time
antarctica after all is a 14 million
square kilometer
minus 60 degrees celsius frozen
hellscape
where your only company is an overweight
black and white waddling bird
whose very existence is a living
embodiment of eternal suffering
but what shackleton actually faced was
believe it or not
worse before even reaching antarctica
shackleton and his men became stuck
when their ship endurance lodged itself
firmly in a dense ice float
deep into the weddell sea where they
remained trapped
for just shy of a year conditions became
desperate
the men were forced to relocate via
sleds to bleak
rocky elephant islands that lay near the
antarctic peninsula
it was the first time their frozen boots
had touched dry land in over 490 days
not that this would have been all that
comforting to the crew the newest human
settlement was on south georgia island
920 miles away across a violent
hurricane-swept open ocean
but shackleton had one thing going for
him
a pair of herculean balls that had spent
the last 12 months fattening up further
on a diet of penguin and seal blubber he
ordered his men to fortify a lifeboat
stuffed it with a mum's provisions and
set out with
five of his best men in search of help
for 14 days the lifeboat and its weary
battered crew
travelled across the open ocean thrashed
by hurricane winds
and yet astonishingly they made it to
south georgia ireland in
one piece but the celebrations did not
last long
shackleton and his men had landed on the
wrong side of the island
separated from civilization by an
uncharted mountain range
and a journey so perilous that british
explorer duncan cars would later say
i do not know how they did it except
that they had to there followed 36 hours
of non-stop
grueling walking scrambling and
climbing up and down perilous mountain
faces
and across unnamed glaciers battered
bruised
and bone weary shackleton and his men
stumbled into stromness whirling station
somehow he had done it and all whilst
dragging those enormous balls along with
him
within three months all 28 men of the
endurance were
saved which no doubt left our friends
deaf
wondering how the do i kill this guy so
what's the final lesson for today there
isn't one
your balls aren't as big as shackleton's
so forget it
thanks for watching you can now
pre-order my brand's new book sticker
flag in it on amazon
link in the description thank you